écoute je t'aime toujours je veux plus
qu'on sans bruit quand on le fait depuis
des mois
en tout cas là ça le fait pas il faut
que ça change sérieux parce que c'est
glee j'en peux plus c'est trop mal je
sais je sais je sais c'est pour ça que
je connais un bébé pour de vrai ouais un
béné ouais tu vois je pense que si on
avait un enfant et mais on arrivera
serez mais comme un grand au monde y
était dit qui dit pas ça pour te fait de
moi je te jure que non je pense que tu
seras une mère qui assure méchamment
monde issus tant comme toi je pense que
je testerai mara si j'étais maman alors
tendu quoi c'est l'accord au tamis moi
aussi je t'aime